this is the guy that Apple CEO Tim Cook
relies on to make
iPhones now he wants to make your
electric
car that's the pitch from Young Liu
foxcon chairman and CEO the Taiwanese
company that assembles your iPhone
PlayStation 5 and Dell laptop bought
this Factory in Ohio and it could
represent the future of electric vehicle
manufacturing foxcon wants to
revolutionize the EV industry by
replicating with automobiles the
streaming line way its 1.2 million
employees make
Electronics so if Apple someday decides
to make a car it's not impossible that
this could be the plant that actually
builds
[Music]
it foxcon whose formal name is hanhai
Technology Group took over this plant in
May 2022 it's had a turbulent few years
it was originally a General Motors
Factory then it was sold to an electric
vehicle startup that later went bankrupt
and now it belongs to foxcon but it's
not exactly operating at full capacity
yet this Factory in Lordstown used to
make more than 300,000 Vehicles a year
now it's owned and operated by foxcon of
Taiwan and it's making well dozens at a
time
now the idea is to scale up and do what
it does best foxcon is a successful
contract manufacturer which means means
it supplies the parts and assembles
devices for other
companies it's the secret sauce that's
driven the company's success for decades
Electronics firms all used to make their
own products but as consumer prices
declined in the ' 80s and '90s so did
profitability that created an
opportunity for foxcon by working for
multiple customers the company gets
discounts on large quantities of raw
materials and components while keeping
its factories running more effici
efficiently the more it manufactures the
more efficient it can be the company's
ability to access cheap labor in China
gives it an edge although it's also
caused problems in the past with some
factories in the country accused of
treating workers so poorly that some
committed suicide foxcon has previously
said that it improved working conditions
and raised wages at plants where
suicides
occurred in 2007 Steve Jobs turned to
foxcon to make the iPhone fueling
further growth the
second is a revolutionary mobile
phone foxcon Revenue surged from $41
billion in 2006 before the iPhone was
released to 222 billion in
2022 so why EVs and why now well Global
smartphone sales are slowing and foxcon
which makes the most iPhones decided it
needs to diversify young Leu set his SES
on this new new
industry uh we did a study when we you
started about uh 3 or 4 years ago at
that time the market at 2025 was
estimated at600 billion US
big Contra manufacturing makes better
sense uh in the EV space is because
there are less moving Parts in EVS there
are less components requires less labor
so basically the whole process is is
much
simpler established tech companies like
Amazon Sony and apple are also dipping
their toes in the water so foxc con's
proposal to both Legacy car companies as
well as any Tech players or startups
eager to get a piece of the electric
vehicle Revolution is the same promise
it once made to Apple come to us and
we'll Supply design or assemble any part
of your car or even the whole thing
faster and more cheaply than you
can the big push to electric vehicles by
Young Leu is evident at company
headquarters in Taipei he and his team
were in full preparation mode for its
annual Tech day this is when they show
off what they can offer prospective
customers and this time around cars were
front and
center right now Magna is the biggest
contract manufacturer of cars for BMW
Mercedes and Audi after decades in the
space though the Austrian Canadian
company still only makes $5 billion a
year from that business foxcon is aiming
for a much higher level of Revenue
otherwise its current Investments won't
make much sense the industry is littered
with examples of electric vehicle
startups that made bold claims about
their products but underestimated the
cost and complexity of setting up
factories that's where FKS count comes
in they say okay we can help you cut
some upfront cost we can help you cut
the production cost foxcon is entering
uncertain territory building electric
cars and smartphones involve similar
skills both contain a battery and a lot
of chips but the scale is
different while an iPhone contains
hundreds of individual components an
electric vehicle has more like 10,000 to
15,000 to cut shipping costs and avoid
tariffs foxcon has said it plans to
build electric vehicles close to where
they're sold but its experience
Manufacturing in the US is minimal and
now we're seeing big downturns within
the industry with auto Giants including
Ford GM and Honda all pulling back from
EVS in the years since foxcon started
making moves in the car industry new
challenges have cropped up uh it's been
a while since foxcon announced the plans
economy outlooks has changed uh growth
are slowing down we have high interest
rates consumers uh they are uh holding
back on car purchases the business
environment is getting tougher for new
startups in the automotive space so how
can foxcom get more clients to use their
Contra Manufacturing Services that will
be something we need to look out for the
next couple of
years that all raises a tantalizing
Prospect maybe the Taiwanese firm needs
Apple to build a car to justify this
huge bet although Apple CEO Tim Cook is
his most valuable customer they are
staying quiet on the possibility for now
but but if an apple car does ever
materialize there's a chance it will
roll off the production line in
[Music]
Lordstown